buffins don't call us buffins so the
Institute of physics has asked tabl like
newspapers here in the UK in the Daily
Star the sun Daily Mirror Daily Mail to
stop using the term buffing some of you
may have heard this term before some of
you on the other side of the pond may
not be familiar with the term buffin but
it's well the Institute of physics would
say it's a disparaging term for for
scientists it's like the typical eggh
head uh sort of typical science fiction
movie you know white coat goggles uh
hair bit fluffier on the sides than mine
but certainly the the the slap head bit
in the middle um sets in mind a certain
stereotype about scientists an
expression from the second world
war and um I think May been Winston
Churchill saying that bofin should be on
tap not on top but it doesn't worry me
very much a new Escape technique
developed by Royal Naval boffins back in
Britain what seems to be much more
important is newspapers should be
talking about
scientists rather than wearing what they
call them among the buffins in the back
room even more remarkable results seem
to have been obtained I can give you one
particular wonderful example personal
example from
1996 this is um from the Nottingham even
Evening Post uh this was my research
supervisor Peter Beaton at the time
that's me slightly less gray slightly
more hair looking down uh microscope
into an ultra high vacuum chamber and as
you can see Tiny disease Buster is City
buffins dream I'm not like personally
deeply offended but I don't like it
still it feels like it's partly saying
that scientists are a different breed
which I don't like either no I mean I
don't have time to have feelings about
scientist buffins I think like we we
owned the word nerd I think we can own
the word bofin as well some would claim
it's a term of endearment and certainly
the tabloids would claim that it's in
ter term of endearment The Institute of
physics on the other hand thinks it just
disparages us it puts in mind all those
different stereotypes and it turns off
younger Generations who want to get into
science because they have a particular
role model when you hear that word
buffing you have a particular person or
type of person in mind and they want to
get rid of it and it's led to this huge
war war of words um between between the
tabloids in the UK and between the
Institute of physics The Institute of
physics obviously set off this campaign
the um the tabloids would have no wanted
to have nothing to do with it apart from
the Daily Mirror to be fair to the Daily
Mirror it said yeah we'll hold our hands
up we'll try not to use it again the
star whose front page most days over the
last year or so seems to be focused on
visits from extraterrestrials the star
is a bit like the US national Inquirer
but has slipped down a few steps below
where the national inquir used to be you
know evidence of World War II bomb or
found on moon that type of thing
Eggheads one term buff and band as they
announc bin the buffing campaign a
common phrase used to describe
scientists as being protested by the
people it refers to with a campaign from
members of The Institute of physics
seeking to knock it on the head once and
for all and then response from the
Tabloid was sign our petition save our
bottom sorry save our buffins not
bottoms save our buffins I'll read it
out I undersigned do solemnly swear that
I will continue to use the word buffins
as it shows how much I love our
scientists because they are dead good at
experiments and talking about things
that no one else understands and the
world would be a perver place without
the weirdos so they wanted to they
wanted to keep the term they want to
keep the term and in fact they're
kicking back heavily and they're not
going to stop using it but you can see
without the weirdos it's frustrating
because from one perspective it's like
why are we worried about this this it
doesn't really matter but from another
perspective sort of words are everything
they do set preconceptions they do
Define certain environments they do
control and tune and sort of I guess
direct how people think of things and so
changing the words does change
perception I would say and particularly
when you get this Perl without the
weirdos you know that's we're not going
to attract teenagers into science if the
tab s are essentially equating scientist
with weirdo get where they're coming
from I just have bigger things to worry
about in terms of the culture within
science than what we're being we're
being called much worse by other people
and you know as women we are being
judged in much worse ways than being
called buffin so that's kind of where my
my concentration lies I used to be a
newspaper journalist and I can see the
problem if you have to use the word
scientists again and again and again in
the one article you kind of want other
words for scientists just just so you're
not being repetitive what what word
would you like like researchers is
another one exactly so you can use
scientists researchers any other
acceptable
words so experts experts yeah and even
then I might quibble with expert at
times but you know there's scientists
research researchers experts um even if
we're talking about engineers or we can
talk about par particular so medical
physicist um biochemist any of those
types of things so so bring in the the
instead of just having this catch all
broad Universal term of scientist or
Worse buff and you know what does that
scientist do or how about using their
names wouldn't that be good we could
just use their names that takes up a lot
of space and and usually there's 50 of
you guys collaborating on any one
project yeah but and colleagues so Dr
Smith and colleagues Professor Smith and
colleagues whatever something along
those lines I just kind of laugh and
that's kind of that's that's okay
because compared to joclyn bbell which I
think it was that that particular
publication Oxford sh mother discovers
this and then it gave gave her body
sizes as in like I'm making these
numbers up like 34 27 55 and I'm like
well you know what if it just says
Bing progress you're worried about the
reputational harm of being described as
bofin do you think it does any rep
ational harm to you guys complaining
about being called buffins it makes you
seem humorless I I agree entirely which
is why when I read this this signup
Edition um from the Star you know it I
find it quite funny I I understand what
they're doing and by bringing this to
the four this back and forth at least
science is in the news I agree entirely
it can make us seem humorless and I
think we have to treat this
with you know a Ry grin and we've got to
you know not come across as paced about
it and it it is quite amusing in many
ways however I still would say on the
buffen thing it is it's setting setting
us up um to be distinct from the rest of
the the the sort of everyday people that
somehow we are a class of our own when
but in this context I feel like you
should be set apart because it's not
John Smith from the Hub who's claiming
to have cured cancer it's someone who is
smarter and clever and done the research
and has done a PhD and has done years
and years of work so you you should be
set apart you should be seen as studious
and separate from the rest of society
because you've done something special in
this context yes on the weekend you
might go to the pub and see a band but
but you're not being spoken about in
that context it do but they do the
buffen term does exactly the opposite of
what you do Brady you bring this camera
in you connect with us you humanize us
this dehumanize us without getting too
pull faced about it but that's I think
that's the point it's a question of sort
of well they're over there how could we
ever understand them and moreover in the
worst cases what that buffin term can do
is sort of go well all the buffins are
just you know they're just off in their
own little world again it's of
absolutely um no practical
use we we why do we need bofin why do we
need Elites why do we need experts so if
you have a if you have a big Discovery
and it's in the The Daily Star you don't
mind if it says Nottingham boffin has
chemical
breakthrough no I don't mind very much I
mean the only time I've been in the
local paper I was described as YouTube
Professor so whether that's a compliment
or an insult I'm not
sure
if you'd like to see more of my videos
with Scientists or researchers experts
whatever you want to call them check out
more 60 symbols for physicists deep sky
videos for
astronomers chemists over at periodic
videos mathematicians at number file
I'll put links to all my channels in the
video description please do go and have
a look and if you like what you see
maybe subscribe